hi I'm David a PRD chairman of the
invest in France agency it's a
governmental agency which provides
information support to Indian companies
and foreign companies more generally
speaking that want to invest in infants
I'm here in the World Economic Forum to
get in touch with a number of
participants focusing on Indian
companies and executives of Indian
companies our objective is to fold I
mean first understand their their plans
the vision of Europe and France in
particular and get in touch with them to
discuss with their investment projects
about their investment projects second
we want to convey the message that
France is a fantastic destination for
their investment companies especially if
they want to develop innovation in the
country we are currently launching an
information campaign on France which
says say we two innovations say we to
France and I am pretty confident that
the new conditions which are offered in
front especially since the Prime
Minister made a public announcement
yesterday that a very strong support
will be given to companies in the form
of 20 billion euros reduction in taxes
will create more favorable environment
and of course be followed by many many
new decisions of investments by Indian
companies thank you